i think movie making is about to change
forever there are millions of movies in
the brains of brilliant people today
that can't be made because they're not
part of the hollywood machine you will
have young filmmakers who have brilliant
ideas who will be able to go to the
world and their audience like we do
today on tick tock and instagram and say
here is my script if you buy an nft from
this movie and here's the image maybe
the nfc is the movie poster the nft is
actually a smart contract for a piece of
the back end of the movie so you read it
you love it you think it would be
amazing movie now you buy four nfts and
you own point zero zero one percent of
the back end of the film but then the
film actually can get made because that
individual has raised enough money from
selling nfps then they make then it goes
out then they own it the audience owns
it and then it gets distribution from
the way ott now works these are things
that i can see from the blockchain that
i don't think people are putting the
pieces together just yet and it will
change the world